han pasado más de dos semanas desde que
los invasores rusos abandonaron las
ciudades alrededor de kiev y las
autoridades ucranianas siguen haciendo
sombríos descubrimientos hasta ahora se
han encontrado más de 900 cuerpos en
varias localidades algunos abandonados
en las calles otros descubiertos en
tumbas temporales la policía dice que
casi todos murieron por heridas de bala
estos son civiles cuyos cuerpos fueron
descubiertos y llevados a exámenes
forenses se trata de más de 900 personas
que fueron asesinadas a manos del
ejército ruso también quiere decir que
muchas tienen un número más
significativo de víctimas esto sugiere
que los ocupantes las unidades que
operaban en muchas fueron las más
brutales se encontraron más de 350
cadáveres en lucha las estremecedoras
imágenes de las atrocidades cometidas
allí conmocionaron al mundo la ciudad se
ha convertido ahora en el centro de las
investigaciones sobre crímenes de guerra
los cuerpos de la esposa y los dos hijos
de alexander fueron encontrados
recientemente en lucha todavía se está
recuperando de sus heridas dice que el
ejército ruso les disparó cuando
intentaban escapar
no les interesaba dónde íbamos ni por
qué
en un partido empezó sin más no les
importaba el bache
las tropas rusas sobre el terreno pueden
haberse ido pero los residentes de kiev
están ahora preocupados por lo que
podría caer desde los cielos ya que
moscú promete intensificar los ataques
con misiles sobre la capital
esto en respuesta a los supuestos
asaltos ucranianos al territorio ruso en
el este del país algo que kiev ha negado